hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday July 8th 2019 what's going on
how's it going
well back to the goddamn grind right
beautiful [ __ ] probably a beautiful
sunny summer day and you got what you
got to feel what it felt like to be a
[ __ ] trust fund kid this entire
weekend right just no [ __ ] nobody
bugging you right other than your
significant other we need more ice can
you go to the store and get some more
ice what do you not know how to drive a
[ __ ] car now well you know I'd like
to enjoy the day too sweetheart
rather than run into the [ __ ] store
every time you just you decide we need
some more [ __ ] dip you know what you
are just getting you're just getting
impossible but come to America the [ __ ]
how's it going man
I'm in a stupid mood it's a Sunday I'm
what I'm recording this and I have a lot
to record congratulations by the way to
the the women's the ladies soccer team
they won the World Cup first lady's team
to ever do that ever
of course it's the USA to go
back-to-back I should say four years ago
they also won a World Cup all right
they're the first ones ever how far back
does women's soccer go like when did
they first let them out to like [ __ ]
allow them to play soccer you don't I
mean all these [ __ ] guys yelling at
them about their hoop skirts you can't
run around you get a [ __ ] you get a
trip and fall and you're gonna flatten
out your teddies and then what then what
you know this is what guys thought back
in the day I'm just trying to give you
guys first
active on women's soccer history of
Women's World Cup all right let's look
this up here what do we got what do we
got the FI F a fiber FIFA the fiber
World Cup is an international football
competition blah blah [ __ ] blah
founded in 1991 out Jesus Christ all
right but still we are the first ones we
are the first ones my friend and we got
the best women in the world doo doo doo
doo anyways they won and I watched
literally seven minutes of it it was
promoted very well I knew it was going
on how about that I just was too busy to
watch it and as I mentioned before I
like lady soccer better than the fellas
because there's a lot less flopping
around yeah I mean when a woman falls
down and cries you got you gotta be like
I what happened a guy falls down across
IKEA [ __ ] [ __ ] get up
really did it hurt that bad with your
little slippers on and I'm gonna get a
bunch of [ __ ] letters from [ __ ]
around the world going yeah but have
somebody step on your toes with cleats
you know yeah I've gotten a hooker
before yeah [ __ ] you feels like a bunch
of stilettos I've never understood that
you ever see that [ __ ] what guys want
like women in stilettos to step on their
balls
yeah well walk on their back like what
the [ __ ] happened to you let's look that
up right who gives a [ __ ] I don't have
any guests with [ __ ] you just listen to
me looking up [ __ ]
why do men like their balls stepped on
this is actually gonna be my search here
let's say clean out my cookies balls
stepped on boot boot but Dippet blue but
the ball stomping foot fetish
interestingly enough is on the observer
calm what do I look up next why do
people want to observe somebody [ __ ]
get their ball why do guys why do some
guys let getting kneed in the testicles
as a fetish
here's another one that's my fetish gang
getting punched in the balls men explain
what they actually want partners to do
with their balls all right here's my
beyond play with them and do not
approach them as though they were a
boPET well I don't know what a bluff it
is but that seems violent loads of
people who don't want to have their own
set of balls
why does having my balls busted by men
turn me on
okay the okay I went into the women [ __ ]
alright hang on a second all right let's
just start with the ball stomping foot
--is-- fetish
heal the world pay for pain shoe guy
lets women walk all over him all right
all right all right we're going through
the stories here you know why can't they
just answer the [ __ ] question you
know when you I don't do this ah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm trying not to flip out
you know I'm [ __ ] sitting there I'm
trying to [ __ ] look up a recipe right
I like to cook I'm a little dainty I fly
around the [ __ ] kitchen every once in
a while you know and you just you just
say something alright I want to make a
[ __ ] pork shoulder or whatever and
then they just can't give you the recipe
these [ __ ] long-winded [ __ ] they got
again - you know ever since the 1600s
pork shoulder has just been a delicacy
why I remember when I was a child the
smell of pork pretty cool kids oh [ __ ]
what happened he was a [ __ ] key to me
so my kids sleeping tell me what the fun
of [ __ ] to make this [ __ ] jesus [ __ ]
christ
all right hang on a second why does some
men like to get their balls stepped on
let's add to the search here quick
answer
ah Jesus I just want to do guys love
their balls being so I eat how to fondle
his balls Jesus Christ
you ever play with your keys in your
pockets ladies it's it's something like
that a lot less noise though anyway I
don't understand that that's [ __ ]
hilarious to me you always might imagine
the hooker you want me to do would you
want me step on your [ __ ] ball I'll
do it give me the money first
I just can't you just sitting there like
these [ __ ] ladies like they got on
those goddamn heels I mean I thought
your balls were like grapes right won't
they blow up and further my even if you
[ __ ] into that how are you walking to
work the next day how was your weekend
Mike encouraged I get all bent over Mike
you're looking a little blue you know he
wears shorts to work that day like
[ __ ] up both sides of the inside of
his thighs I like [ __ ] purple that's
when the whispering starts did he have
ball cancer no you know what I heard do
you know what I know Maggie from
accounting went out to him don't listen
listen everything was going great they
went to the ground round they had some
peanuts and they threw the shells on the
fluo then all of a sudden he gets back
to his apartment he's kissing her
he's fondling her tits she's getting
into it right they got gymkata on in the
background so it's really romantic and
all of a sudden out of nowhere he goes
all right you know I'm a little
different which you know is a red flag
so I'm thinking he wants me to look as
it has to stop but now he [ __ ] straps
himself to a chair pulls out of his
balls it tells me to put on a pair of
shoes in the store bought oh my god what
did you do I [ __ ] kicked him in the
booth I mean how do you even tell that
story I don't understand how to [ __ ] you
like how do you even begin to bring that
up you know what I mean that just goes
so far down the [ __ ] road and just
disappears around a corner
women have you ever had that can you
write in you've ever had a guy say he
wants to get his balls stepped on you
know I'm usually I don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody wants to do but I mean you
could really hurt somebody you know
imagine if a woman said that to you what
do you like tell me what you like
well it's my PC might be crazy but you
got a pair of Converse All Star high
tops was a matter of fact I do
yeah well could you put one of them on
and take a running leap and just boot me
right in the [ __ ] I would be like no no
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
[ __ ] hilarious
you know you get with a woman and she
likes it a little bit rough that I can't
imagine now these [ __ ] poor people
these full [ __ ] poor guys out there
you get some [ __ ] crazy chick it's
just like I'm not [ __ ] doing that
you want me to choke you and what have
my fingerprints on your [ __ ] neck now
I'm not doing that all right you got
some gloves this is this is where we're
at
I guess sit here and act like I'm
robbing a [ __ ] house just to have sex
with you I don't want to do this I'm not
into this [ __ ] all right anyways I don't
want to talking about this is what
happens you do a podcast by yourself you
just you go down a rabbit hole every
once in a while but anyway what I think
I was trying to say in all of that
congratulations to the leis you know
they beat the Netherlands right with
their little Lauren I don't understand
why they're wearing the Irish orange
they're from the Irish flag I have no
[ __ ] idea how depth oh let me let me
look up there [ __ ] you know this would
be a whole podcast looking up [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] FBI looking at me it's
billed Oh fill the file on this guy he
wants to go to [ __ ] the Netherlands
and have his balls stepped on he
whispers a lot there right Netherlands
Beth flag is red white and blue why
orange not right the colours came from
the prints of NASA's coat of arms the
orange craze can be traced back to the
very roots of the Netherlands oranges
the color of the Dutch royal family they
must have been a bunch of changes
the lift like that whatever happened
like they would ever allow a family of
redheads to rule anybody all right let's
look that up let's see we got here
history of red head royalty red hair and
royalty ice there's nothing that you can
[ __ ] search that there isn't at least
somebody attempting to answer it it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's like my that
cliff Clavin Oh what you got there don't
you see that somebody let's just this is
literally somebody this is what happens
when you have 7 billion people can you
imagine if we had the right population
you know which people say is like
underneath a billion I mean what the
farmers did they say I have no firing
hang on a second let's check that out
how many people wait no ideal population
what is the ideal population of the
world please just give me a you know
ever since the caveman days people have
been [ __ ] 1.5 to 2 billion all right
let's just say 1.5 okay well we're gonna
we're gonna error to her to the [ __ ]
lower all right you get 1.5 billion
people in there lit so Kay I don't know
why the [ __ ] I looked at okay red hair
and royalty all right the following
article is pretty much a list on a Wagyu
feels only 1.5 billion people on the
planet you know they probably still
would be an answer to every [ __ ]
question and at least a goddamn attempt
the following article is pretty much
just a list of redhead Royals I'll throw
a few URLs and Holy Roman emperors
What's in URLs that look an uncle in the
royal family mrs. Meyer laddie
he's the balls he buys me [ __ ] be
is you know he doesn't rat me out to the
king he's a good [ __ ] now he was
supposed to be king he got busted
drinking and driving and that was it
all right henry ii richard the lionheart
was a redhead
he's got a big heart he's got a big
heart in orange pubes I mean you gotta
love the guy Elizabeth Woodville
Elizabeth of York Elizabeth the first
a lot of Liz's out there Alexander the
second King of Scotland Mary Queen of
the Scots that's it all those kings and
queens out there that's all we got we
got one two three four five six seven
and [ __ ] four of them were ladies so
there was basically henry ii richard the
lionheart and alexander ii King of
Scotland you know they don't give a [ __ ]
every other [ __ ] person's out there
is a goddamn right edge right so [ __ ]
cloudy they're always looking down at
the ground looking at the raindrops so
they don't even notice it by the time
they realize they got a [ __ ] ginger
in office they don't give a [ __ ] right
as long as the beers are flowing all
right
anyway so the ladies won the [ __ ]
World Cup for the second time that's
awesome man you know I enjoy watching
that [ __ ] and it's also [ __ ]
hilarious so my friends call up dude
some of these chicks are [ __ ] hot
like it doesn't it's like that's not
what this is about
all right rub one out and sit down and
realize the level of pressure that's
going on here and these people are
delivering you know oh man this [ __ ]
guy pissed me off the oh let me tell you
ho ho ho this guy pissed me off I was
crossing the street all right the walk
sign had turned to the numbers and it's
counting down right and I got plenty of
time to get across and this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] in an SUV as I'm walking in
front he's peep in the horn like peep
peep
like like pit let's pick it up so I do
the classic put the arms out like he you
[ __ ] serious you know and he's got
like it like his bumper and [ __ ] his
grille is in the [ __ ] crosswalk right
it's a classic New York
right so I get halfway I turn around it
you know look at the guy what the [ __ ]
and I keep walking and as he drives away
he goes that he goes that's not a [ __ ]
sign that's a countdown like what the
[ __ ] does that mean
does that mean what countdown to what
you're gonna [ __ ] run you still can't
go in when the numbers are going down it
was one of the things that he drove away
it was nothing I could say quick enough
I wish I had like the presence of mind
to just yell oh you know we're not true
wrong that's a good one
somebody's driving away and you want to
hear what you know if you driving by
somebody and you want them to hear you
you have to slow down or you got to get
right to it that's gonna be my new go-to
word when to anybody yells anything you
redheaded [ __ ] you know homophobic
slur that you can't say anymore I'll
just go yeah but the guy was so
convinced of it I actually had to look
it up I looked that up too I looked that
up all right and it's it's not a count
like it is still a walk sign that's
telling you how much time you have left
in the crosswalk then the [ __ ] hand
comes up when the hand is like blinking
that means to run and then when it says
stop that means don't walk your [ __ ]
oh my god I I fantasized of somehow
catching up to him and punching him in
the face
through his [ __ ] window that's like
the ultimate like if I was the
Terminator that's what I would do I
wouldn't be walking out you'll saticon
a-- i would just be waiting for [ __ ]
drivers like that to be doing [ __ ] like
that and then that's when i would
unleash my metal hand alright if I was a
terminator I would actually go through
the [ __ ] the windshield and then do
it you know there's actually I don't get
into conspiracy theory but believe it or
not there's actually real terminators
walking around amongst us all right and
the media tries to cover it up saying
that they're on bath salts it's not true
they're not like that's not [ __ ] true
okay cuz if bath salts made you eat a
homeless person or [ __ ] gouge out
your own eyeballs you know if you did
[ __ ] like that like no one would take
the drug okay what you're dealing with
there is is defective terminators that
got confused okay they're not supposed
to get caught and then they get caught
and then they just act like the human
you know it's a default program they
just allow themselves to get arrested
that's [ __ ] true when you you know
what you can look that up you know what
I'm gonna look that up right now what's
Lucy we got you real terminators walking
I'm gonna get real specific amongst us
alright now this this will definitely
get to conspiracy six scientific
scientific advantage advances bringing
us closer to a realtor minute that's not
what I'm looking for that sounds like
they get facts here come the real
terminators The Washington Post
okay that's scary you know what I'm
gonna look at that one I've heard of The
Washington Post they're a newspaper up
there in Seattle actually it's
Washington DC I went to an East Coast
College shut the [ __ ] up
with us sandals in your [ __ ] hairy
bush the two year DARPA Robotics
Challenge which will hand out innovation
prize money of two teams that can build
a robot capable of walking over rubble
manipulating complex tools driving
utility vehicles and performing a number
other of other disaster response
operations has the potential to create
the first generation of emergency first
responder robots now here's the funny
thing about that this is this is the
question you should be asking yourself
this is this is what I think if I had a
website this is what I would be writing
about all right human beings can do all
of that we can already do all that so
what the [ __ ] are you wasting all this
money coming up with these things unless
these things are our replacements okay
except for the super-rich right
I gotta look up something right now how
many redheads are in the Illuminati
[Music]
science shows redheads have genetics
superpowers out Jesus Christ that is one
article away from being called a witch
and getting drowned in Salem
how many redheads are in the world
red hair lizard people the greatest
political conspiracy ever created 11
things you didn't know about redheads
you know what let's see if I know this
[ __ ]
alright the redheads come from another
planet do they have superpowers
these aren't uncommon questions throwing
around at the ginger community alright
just get to the [ __ ] look redheads
don't turn into vampires when they die
that's number one
redheads they haven't had it easy come
on you guys know what you did to us
three technically they are mutants the
gene that causes red hair which is
recessive I like to call it special
comes from the mc1r which is a genetic
mutation movies have led to me believe
that this also means that redheads have
hidden mutant powers right now
Jesus you're trying to be funny mutant
superpowers left-handedness oh [ __ ] I'm
left-handed sometimes depends on what
I'm doing you know Newton's genes
apparently like to hang out together so
if you have red hair you are most likely
to be left-handed and that doesn't sound
real
now redheads are more sensitive to
temperature why it has to do with our
fair-skinned everybody in [ __ ]
Ireland is they never go gray they just
go a weird yellow color everything hurts
them more than it hurts you I actually
heard that that it [ __ ] they have a
higher threshold for pain but then again
you know you look Scotland and Ireland
are winning the competition
redheads have less hair on their head so
that goes without saying with me they
are better at generating vitamin D yeah
take that brunettes they are not going
extinct Elle we're here to stay baby
alright that was boring alright can I
read some [ __ ] advertising here what
was I talking I don't know what the [ __ ]
I was talking about I was talking about
[ __ ] the the the the real terminators
ideal population all right so why are
they why are they making these [ __ ]
things did Defense Advanced Research
Project agency anticipates that at least
one winning team will be able to create
a robot see if they do it to nerds
okay they never got picked in gym class
now they're all excited that they're on
a [ __ ] team you know they're finally
gonna win something cuz it doesn't
involve some sort of athletic ability
and they're all [ __ ] excited thinking
maybe now maybe now I finally get the
bang of [ __ ] cheerleader and what are
they doing they're actually creating
they're basically they're gonna kill all
of us that's why I [ __ ] hate nerds
they could they they're so they've lost
so much during their childhood you know
and they're so gifted with their [ __ ]
intelligence and they give it to the
wrong [ __ ] people
Donald Trump is a redhead he is now
anyways and you know what he's the one
he's the one who's gonna be take
advantage of these [ __ ] robots that
you make him alright so they're gonna
robot capable of performing eight
different tasks as part of one
continuous physical disaster scenario
why do they have to use disaster by 2014
well you know what that was [ __ ] five
years ago and I don't see anybody
knocking on my door
yo Sadek gonna ah you'll shout out god
ah
alright I think it's time for some
[ __ ] advertising I don't know about
you guys you know let's let's cleanse
the palate with a little bit of
capitalism shall we do they have
commercials in Russia are you allowed to
what do you have that is your family in
gulag do they get cold after being
tortured when they go to gulag
good luck sounds like a [ __ ] I know
it sounds like something you'd get in
[ __ ] New Orleans a big pot of it big
pot of gulag no sudden there's somebody
chick with a [ __ ] chicken flip
looking at you alright zip you know
hiring used to be hard it's not as hard
as being a woman but it's really hard
multiple job sites stacks of resumes a
confusing reviewing process wait am I
supposed to ask the questions or do you
I don't even know what's going on but
today hiring can be easy and you only
have to go to one place to get it to get
it good zip you know calm / / zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there other people stop there
these guys keep going oh these ladies
are these days these days keep going to
those Dems with their powerful matching
gait who's gonna who's gonna claim them
what da I'm a [ __ ] Shetland Sheepdog
trapped in a [ __ ] day that used to be
a he that was banging as she with their
powerful their powerful machine
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of [ __ ] resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip Neruda analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
is often it so affected that four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the first day and right now my
listeners can try zip recruit for free
at this exclusive website address zip
recruited comm / / that zip recruited
comm / / zip dot-com / / spell it out zi
p r ec rui ter it's the smartest way to
hire do you like zip recruiter I I just
think that's just the smartest way to
hire policy genius by the way if you
don't if you're not following Trump on
Twitter evidently he is an incredibly
stable genius can you argue it you can't
you can't argue the genius part because
there's no [ __ ] way that guy should
have got elected and he did and there's
a genius to that all right if you don't
think so you're liberal [ __ ] why don't
you run for office and let's see how the
[ __ ] you do all right part of adulthood
is having to do things that you don't
really want to do like red-eye flights
working late
visiting in-laws and getting life
insurance but another part of adulthood
is learning to delegate what you hate oh
my god look I love this copy this is
copy and it's great life advice that is
exactly you got to learn to delegate
listen if I've learned anything you
can't do it all yourself so if you can't
do it all yourself
get rid of this [ __ ] you hate why not
women do it why not you as a guy honey
can you help me lift up the refrigerator
no I think your sisters looking you know
her shoulders are pretty broad and she
is a broad but oh you guys [ __ ]
handle it and while you can't delegate a
visit to the in-laws you can't
definitely delegate life insurance
shopping policy genius is the best way
to shop for life insurance online it's
just - in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price once you apply the
policy genius team
handle all the paperwork and red tape no
sales pressure no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
they can also help you find the right
home insurance auto insurance and
disability insurance so your ass is
covered for whatever so if you need life
insurance but you don't just want to
deal with all the legal work head to
policy genius com it's the easiest
easiest it's an easy way to compare all
the top insurers and find the best value
for you policy genius delegate what you
hate especially if you hate getting life
insurance I was hoping I was gonna rhyme
delegate what you hate and then your ass
is gonna feel great policy genius go
[ __ ] you some all right
shout out to everybody in California
dealing with those earthquakes and in
Las Vegas and all that crap I actually
missed all of it which I'm happy about
cuz I've been in a bunch of earthquakes
and you know what I don't like it it's
not fun to me I'm not one of these
[ __ ] locals in LA that starts
chuckling I got some upcoming dates I
want to tell you about first of all the
most important upcoming date is July
12th Comedy Central guys I need you on
this one
I'd [ __ ] around on this podcast I'm
asking you I'm calling in a favor can
you guys please stay home and watch Ian
Edwards one of the greatest comics out
there that for whatever reason people
don't know about all right he's gonna be
on Joe Rogan's podcast he's opening for
Rogan out in Vegas I believe he told me
this guy is a [ __ ] monster he did he
did the Patrice O'Neal benefit and I got
emails for like three months going who
the [ __ ] was that guy Ian Edwards new
stand-up special produced by the
geniuses the incredibly stable geniuses
at all things comedy the podcast network
that I do with al Madrigal Bert
Kreischer in a cast of [ __ ] thousands
is airing July 12th on Ari Shaffir
airing July 12th on Comedy Central
please sit down and watch it so he gets
the ratings and you know I'm telling you
just because they're doing a bunch of
[ __ ] you know progressive hiring
doesn't mean they're taking the time to
actually find the right people in those
groups you know your eminence Seinfeld
bit you know about the reservation
anybody can take a reservation you start
snapping and anybody can take one
holding the reservation that's the heart
of it so that's this anybody can [ __ ]
find a female comp but finding the right
one actually taking the time to do your
homework so when you're finally going to
give these people an opportunity you
actually pick the funniest [ __ ]
people out there that's the hard part
that's where ATC comes in all right Ian
Edwards is our progressive hire I'm just
[ __ ] you had nothing to do with that
I just picked him because he's [ __ ]
hilarious all right
July 12th on Comedy Central all right I
have some upcoming stand-up dates all
right and just let's just let you know I
will be wearing a skirt for no reason
on this next with pants my new my new my
new stand-up tour all right I'm running
out of ideas okay I want to I want to be
considered an ally Foxwood Resort and
Casino in Connecticut almost of
Connecticut Massachusetts in Connecticut
New England all right
August 11th and then I'm at the
Cosmopolitan I added another date there
I'm at least my agent did and I was like
I don't want to do it he said listen
buddy you [ __ ] work for me so now I'm
going back
December 21st but buttered up pop pop
pop buttered up but but just see those
[ __ ] jean shorts waddling down the
strip they walk a 500 and they've
watched flow is [ __ ] get the [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of the way
it's still a hundred degrees go get a
[ __ ] sundae you eat it up beat it up
and then you die sticky outside and
watch you fry and then we feed you to
[ __ ] Mountain liar
sorry anyways those I'm gonna I'm gonna
be out there in those dates
Foxwoods casino also I'm doing the
Travis Roy benefit August first and what
do you call it there the the Wilbur oh
my god August 11th I'll actually be
wrapped on the movie Jesus Christ so you
will not see a mustachioed freckled face
on that date you know um it's gonna be
an event when I shave off the moustache
I'm thinking I'm letting Nia do it it's
gonna be on our Instagram page she's
gonna shave it off like when they shaved
off Burt Reynolds [ __ ] moustache in
the longest yard
I'm gonna find a lazy boy recliner
reclined back she's gonna put a hot
towel on my face she's gonna put on some
stilettos she's gonna [ __ ] stop my
balls and as I scream in horror she's
gonna shave off half of it tell me to go
[ __ ] myself and walk out that's the game
plan okay
that's the first draft of the script
I'll let you know how it goes
congratulations to my Mac guys winning
another race that son of a [ __ ] that's
all he does is win he's got four wins
this year three second places and one
did not finish at the with the one down
there in Austin when he had the [ __ ]
race won and he wiped out like he looked
like me on a [ __ ] motorcycle in that
moment he's got a fifty eight point lead
over Andres divisio so I don't know it's
it's it's he's running away with it it's
still so [ __ ] exciting I absolutely
love it I missed the race this morning
because you know I got a kid so I'll be
watching later on this week but he won
again and by the way last night I did
some spots down at the Comedy Cellar
I actually did the fat black pussycat
and I did the Village Underground and
thanks to everybody down there for
getting me up put me on didn't whatnot
and after that I went over to Jim
Norton's with Bobby Kelly and we watched
the UFC event where we watched a men
Nunez is that he said that was Nunez
Nunez Amanda Nunez who's you know i
undestand disputable the greatest
[ __ ]
female champion of all time she
literally beat everybody my favorite one
was when she beats cyborg you know I
know they say she doesn't [ __ ] use
the roids but come on man
okay she looks like [ __ ] Jay Leno
Holly Holm
did she beat Holly Holm who I D not Leia
both of them I [ __ ] love both of them
but that was a great fight and it's
funny you know when Holly Holm does that
[ __ ] pacing back and forth in the
beginning rape love the fight she's like
[ __ ] got all that energy that would
the first four years of my stand-up
career that's how I did stand-up I would
just paced back and forth like that
talking way too fast and none of my
movement had anything to do with what
the [ __ ] I was talking about pouring
sweat just a [ __ ] mess and then this
[ __ ] I mean I haven't even been up on
the UFC stuff anyway evidently this has
been this guy Ben Askren and he's been
talking a lot of [ __ ] which is always
great you know makes you want to watch
the fight if it's funny you root for him
if he comes off like a dick you just sit
down won't you so we knocked his [ __ ]
guy out right so I guess he's been doing
that and there was a time he put he look
like he had this guy in like a headlock
my big brother used to put me in and for
some reason the ref thought this guy
tapped out and he didn't he actually
gave the thumbs up and this guy got the
win and they asked him if he was gonna
be a gentleman to give the guy a rematch
he's like now why should I write
cementing himself as a douche right
which is I'm not saying that's a bad
thing you need a douche you need us you
need in the fight game you got to have
that [ __ ] person that everybody hates
cuz I think they're gonna sell the fight
so he's fighting this guy I hope I say
this guy's name right
Jorge Maz Vidal I'm white I'm sorry okay
Jorge and he was really saying like I'm
gonna beat this guy's [ __ ] fate he was
on Rogen's podcast just like you know
yeah he wasn't being funny he was
literally going I'm gonna beat this
guy's [ __ ] face in I [ __ ] hate
this guy
and I don't I don't know ruin spoiler
alert I don't want to ruin this
five-second fight
he came out and redefined the right
there Fred he [ __ ] the [ __ ] it
looked like somebody trying to tackle a
car he the [ __ ] bell rings he just
runs full speed right at the guy and I
don't know what the guide the guy was
like I'm gonna go for a [ __ ] takedown
and then he also his head was kind of
like wow that guy's running really fast
it'd be like trying to tackle somebody
on a [ __ ] motor scooter who also is a
champion UFC fighter that's how fast
this [ __ ] guy was going and just
jumped in the air flying me and hit this
guy right in the side of the head and
this guy he looked like he had rigor
mortis it was actually scary and my only
thing that I don't like about the UFC is
after you're clearly knocked out you
always take another two [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know really hard punches to the
[ __ ] head I saw that twice last night
but to be honest with you with a there's
only these guys are so [ __ ] fast
there's only so fast that the ref can
get in there he's trying to stay out of
the way so wasn't the refs fault but
Jesus Christ five so you can watch he
can the highlight is the whole fight
they Rogan was actually saying it was
really a two second fight because the
guy was out immediately and it just took
the the ref another two punches to get
over there but Jesus Christ Wow as all I
can say about that that was [ __ ]
unbelievable congratulations to Jorge
there's no [ __ ] way I'm going to try
to pronounce your last name because I
don't want to piss you off by butchering
your name with my whiteness here and and
I hope that guy Ben's doing all right
jesus [ __ ] christ I mean that was a
career ender when you're [ __ ] laying
I was with Norton go look at his [ __ ]
toes ago Bobby said his toes a [ __ ]
curled up
there's something to happen to you
whenever you get [ __ ] knocked out
like that your legs always end up being
crossed usually one of your arms is sort
of like up you know you know I do that
like both their arms are up you know
it's almost like they got like it's like
it's saying like they're in a Batman
movie and they're they're like the bad
dancer at a wedding and they get frozen
in the worst [ __ ] position possible
and then there was the championship
fight which unfortunately I really
should know the guys name the guy he's
like [ __ ] out like a blown-out ACL
and he was fighting that wasn't Jack
Johnson right isn't that the [ __ ] guy
right Steph was originally a boxer and
then it was somehow a white guy with a
guitar who's Jack Johnson yeah that's a
white guy with a guitar and he's on yeah
he sings those songs like bah he says he
just started singing along dee dee dee
doo like scat singing burrs II had some
of that someone played that verse he's
[ __ ] backyard party I was just like
this is what okay Jack Johnson's a boxer
okay that's not the [ __ ] guy
all right UFC results have you ever
heard somebody look at more [ __ ] Jon
Jones got the decision Jesus Christ over
a thigh go Santos I don't know I was not
if I was I don't know I don't know
anything about but that that Santos guy
was [ __ ] amazing and I thought John
Jones was doing that championship thing
where he knows you gotta beat the
champion to beat him just the fact that
the fight ended with Jones sort of
running away from him I [ __ ] I don't
know if that that I don't know [ __ ]
about it but I was just saying you can't
throw another couple punches what are we
doing here I have enough points
therefore there's no reason for me to
get near him oh look at this they got
that they got the [ __ ] you do guys
saw saw Rogen's [ __ ] reaction that's
great that's great uh do you know Jill
Rove is one of the greatest bar casters
ever
I mean I mean Ian's and he's gonna he's
gonna go into broadcasting Hall of Fame
there's no [ __ ] way there's no
[ __ ] way
who else can say they did that huh all
right with 40 minutes in let's get to
the [ __ ] questions here all right Oh
sudden all these ladies are writing in
I'm loving it here oh by the way I meant
meaning to talk about this that Yankees
Red Sox game that was in London by the
way was so [ __ ] fixed it was
ridiculous okay and you got to give a
shout out to Joe Buck when it's like
[ __ ] 98 to 2 when the three hours in
and it's the fourth [ __ ] inning and
he's got to sit there and talk you know
all his broadcaster friends sit down and
[ __ ] watch what the hell's he gonna
talk about now they knew they knew they
couldn't go over and show a boring
pitchers dude they had to go out there
and just everybody had to go yard the
game was like literally like [ __ ] 19
to 15 our responses from a lady having
said that the Yankees I mean they gotta
be odds on favorite that they're just
not losing although last night they lost
Devil Rays had a walk-off home run but
like they're just it's amazing what
they're doing this year so you know as I
said you know they win this year they'll
have gone a century worth of deck
decades the last ten decades 90 years I
know that doesn't make sense but it does
it started in the 20s we're still in the
teens okay trust me I worked it out with
my public school math here
they'll have won at least one title in
every decade except for the 80s you know
and if George Steinbrenner didn't have
such a [ __ ] hard-on for Dave Winfield
and start falling around whatever the
[ __ ] he was doing they wouldn't know no
they would have won one then George
Steinbrenner by the way one of the most
overrated [ __ ] owners of all time
I'll argue that with you
I will alright he lucked out in the
beginning because that cheap [ __ ] in the
from the Oakland A's yeah their owner
what didn't want to pay anybody so he
had a [ __ ] dynasty team just floating
around out there and he [ __ ] bought
all the guys he needed and then they won
in 77 78 then he kept trying to do that
for the rest of his [ __ ] and never
[ __ ] worked never worked then he gets
suspended and that's what built up the
[ __ ] his next dynasty and they [ __ ]
it up buying all these [ __ ] guys
there was nothing he liked better than a
37 year old future hall-of-famer with
half a tank left
he there's nothing he liked better than
giving
[ __ ] ten million dollars alright
response from a lady dear Billy big
beard mustache a huge fan Linton listen
up from a lady two things I want to
write about one I also struggle with
holding my tongue at the park in regards
to other people's children oh good you
make me feel better especially when the
children are much older than mine my son
is a small five year old and while at a
splash pad parenthesis water but not
swimming I'm familiar with these these
obese nine to twelve year olds were
shoving my son and threw him to the
ground running past him at full speed
and knocking him older over I yelled out
hey and no to the other kids the mom of
course was pissed that I yelled out yeah
these [ __ ] parents today don't yell
at my kid well he's a fat sweaty [ __ ]
animal why don't you stop feeding him
and once you talk to him turn him into a
young adult rather than solving
everything with the [ __ ] banana split
you dumb [ __ ] I can't say any of that
you know if I was making America great
again you'd be able to say that to
another parent at a [ __ ] playground
she okay the mom of course was pissed
that I yelled out after that she would
yell out those are my boys
those are my boys be the alpha male and
stare at me like she wanted a
confrontation or she would have got one
you should run some stiletto heels and
kicked her right in the [ __ ] mind you
she is also an obese tall individual and
I was afraid that if I confront of her
confronted her she'd sit on me now [ __ ]
that fat [ __ ] this is all you do you get
in their wheelhouse you hop in and you
hop out that's how you beat a fat guy
you hop in
they [ __ ] overcommit alright unless
they know what they're doing but you
never know nowadays but say they don't
you hop in they think they got you
they lunge for you and then you hop out
and then gravity takes over and then
they faceplant
alright and then they're laying face
down but it's like a turtle it's upside
down and you leave them there and you
let them bake and think about what they
did
that's how you beat a fat parent without
throwing a punch all right I don't know
if that's works but it sounds good
doesn't it
I noticed people are doing less to
ensure their children are are doing less
to ensure their children a little [ __ ]
shits it seems like every time we are at
the park
there's ruff kids who are absolute
savages and their parents just don't
give a [ __ ] if they're bullying other
kids yeah yeah when they start doing is
natural selection
whatever just know this you just protect
your kid and know that someday that
[ __ ] [ __ ] it will be shoveling [ __ ]
into a truck and I literally mean [ __ ]
in regards to the women the woman whose
friend whose blunt aka a total [ __ ]
I'm also very large-breasted but my
frame is very small and I can say I've
never had an issue with that being taken
seriously by men they'll see my rack on
sight yes but it's not likely they only
see a walking pair of tits well even if
they do I mean you should be able to
within it within a couple of questions
you should be you should figure out you
know that you know that that's all the
guys into right I've had plenty of
meaningful relationships as an adult
with the large chest [ __ ] that lady and
[ __ ] all of those friends if I were a
friend and someone in that circle said
that I didn't leak all the woman out on
being a dick thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
what a great I like this person I like
people who see the world the way I do
you agree with me you're a good person I
like you I don't like to be challenged
with other opinions alright cigars and
anger Oh sir please don't take the one
vice I have left please don't take this
from me cigars and anger dear Billy
black lung you don't inhale cigars I
know you're right you often talk about
dealing with anger and trying to control
it as someone who has smoked cigarettes
on and off for many years I believe some
of your anger issue may simply may
simply be due to nicotine withdrawal
nicotine is one of the most addictive
substances on earth and by smoking
cigars on and off every few weeks you
are constantly addicting your brain to
nicotine and then putting it through
withdrawal well if I if I smoke it every
couple of weeks that I'm not addicted to
it so what the second I puff it's then
addicted is that what you're saying
what drawl can cause anger irritation in
a short temper I agree with that have
you ever tried a long period of time
away from cigars yes and I was still an
angry [ __ ] I think it might really help
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself Josh in New
Zealand all right I Love New Zealand all
right hang on a second let's look this
up here the nicotine is one of the most
addictive substances cigar every two
weeks
addiction question mark six surprising
facts about cigar smoking I'm not going
any to ten surprising things you didn't
know about redheads that's just
clickbait questions and answers about
cigar smoking and cancer oh boy oh boy
oh boy one of the health risks
associated emanate has shown that
cancers of oral cavity lip tongue mouth
and throat larynx lung and a Savia
associate with cigar smoking furthermore
evidence strongly suggests a link
between cigar smoking cancer the
pancreas
in addition daily cigar smokers
particularly those who inhale are at
risk of developing heart and lung
disease I don't do it daily like
cigarette smoking the risks from cigar
smoke to increase with increased
exposure for example compared with
someone who has never smoked smoking
only one or two cigars per day doubles
the risk for oral and I I don't do that
smoking three to four cigars daily
connect I don't do that what is the risk
of insulation I don't do that how are
cigars and cigarettes different cigars
and cigarettes differ in both size and
type of tobacco use cigarettes are
generally more uniform in size and
contain less than one gram of tobacco
each cigars nearly Han can vary in size
and shape and Commission more than seven
inches large cigars typically contain
between 5 and 17 grams of tobacco is not
unusual
for some premium cigars to contain the
tobacco equivalent of an entire pack of
cigarettes oh boy
yeah I know I need to cut them but I
don't think it's I don't think it's
affecting my temper my temper is it
comes from childhood issues I'd love to
blame it on cigars I would love to just
quit cigars and all of a sudden I don't
have a short [ __ ] temper or maybe
you're just saying if I wasn't I'm
adding to my temper by doing that I
don't know I smoke one every two weeks
all right if that's gonna [ __ ] kill
me that's gonna kill me all right I'm
not gonna go my life okay I don't drink
anymore
I I don't I don't watch internet porn I
don't I don't eat sweets I mean can I
can I just have a [ __ ] cigar every
two weeks
can I do that please
actually I had my first cigar in 12 days
on July 4th and then I had two more the
very next day and I smoked two and a
half the day before yeah I just go nuts
when I do it and I won't do it for like
two [ __ ] weeks I spits bad you're
right it's bad I should just smoke one
I'll smoke one how about one a month can
I do that chick [ __ ] all right George
[ __ ] Burns
he always was smoking cigars he was fine
all right fiance problem hello bill the
shiny head bur boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo had a very shiny head big fan of
your stand-ups and a bigger fan of your
podcast Lana thank you very much I'm a
30 year old man engaged with the 25 year
old woman congratulations we meet at
work got together after a few months and
engaged within six months from the
beginning of our relationship one month
into our relationship I moved in with
her and her mother to share rent as we
are living in the UK and we are from
Eastern Europe that's why I knew you
were from somewhere because you were
like I'm a big fan of your stand-ups all
was fine for a while but then she
started correcting everything I do from
the way I walk eat talk think behave and
even the music I listened to in my
private time
I'm a classic rock fan by the way but
the most pressing issue is that she
doesn't like my mother
and my family and wants me to have more
of a distant relationship with her
that's the one thing I can understand
you're living with them right oh you
moved in with her and her mother oh wait
you're living with her mother and she's
giving you [ __ ] about your family get
the [ __ ] out of here
anyways doesn't want our future kids
spending time alone with my mom all
right dude I'm half way through this and
you yeah I knew [ __ ] five sentences
ago you got to break up with this person
I kept a distance for about four months
but after an argument with my fiancee
sends me my fiancee sends me a I'm sick
and tired of you you will never achieve
anything in life text message and I
caved and called my mother for advice we
need caved and called your mother dude
you're looking at this ass backwards
[ __ ] this person this person wants to
break up with you but doesn't know how
to do it advice on how to deal with this
I did lie about talking with my mother
afterwards but confessed to it to her
later and apologized but now my fiance's
mad at you for talking to your mother
my question to you is it normal for a
person you are with to demand that I
changed everything no that she doesn't
like about me just to be with her any
advice from you with a lovely Nia is
helpful thanks and happy go [ __ ]
yourself sorry for the bad English yeah
break up with this person alright she's
talking about the way you walk he can't
talk to your mom it's like you're
[ __ ] shooting heroin something you
got a crazy temper like me when people
call you out on that [ __ ] she's talking
about the music you listen to oh my god
that'd be the easiest breakup ever
can you imagine going from that
relationship sir to some woman that
actually enjoyed how you walked and let
you listen to your music and didn't you
know got along with your mom and you
could actually talk to your own mother
yeah that woman is out there that would
be most women that you're gonna date
you've got a [ __ ] psycho on your
hands and you got to back the Trump up
sir
people dump that [ __ ] right out the back
right on the side of the street take the
ticket who gives a [ __ ] all right
my husband's fault bill thought this
video summed up my marriage pretty well
this is called husband's fault all right
I'm playing if it's a cat near a pool
[Music]
this guy sneezes makes the cat jump and
land in a pool and then his [ __ ] wife
gives him [ __ ] what's this no I'm not
allowed that is [ __ ] hilarious all
right Jesus Christ is gonna plate nine
times in a row what's funny about that
is she gives him [ __ ] but he doesn't
even give a [ __ ] about that I sneezed
I'm not allowed to [ __ ] sneeze
there's a lot there's a lot in that
video there's a lot of past history
going on in that [ __ ] who knows he
probably did some [ __ ] - nice Ron you
can see she just sees she's settled with
what he's gonna do in life
all right boyfriends weight from a lady
I bill I'm a 24 year old lady and I've
been with my redheaded boyfriend for a
year and a half now you can't be a fat
ginger you just can't do it man you
gotta you gotta gotta get on the
elliptical here all right when we first
started dating we both gained the
relationship weight from always eating
out back in January both decided to try
and lose the relationship weight I lost
mine and more while my boyfriend has not
well there's a quick way to lose your
girlfriend I struggled with weight my
whole life and take diet and exercise
seriously I've tried to nicely tell him
how he should try to be healthier yeah
he's [ __ ] he's 24 years old he's
already a fat [ __ ] boy wouldn't even
look at 34 44 54 you gone you're gonna
die I've tried to tell him how he should
be healthier and I'll tell you got all
these [ __ ] advertising now
people evidently thrilled and you know
yeah take a picture of them now they're
not gonna be here being overweight is
not a [ __ ] joke I'm gonna cut down on
my [ __ ] cigar smoking and you know
you got to keep the [ __ ] weight off
you just got to do it you have to do it
this whole [ __ ] new world where you
know you can't call somebody a fat [ __ ]
I agree with that [ __ ] but in the same
thing you don't [ __ ] champion like
they just want a war cuz they eat a
whole box of [ __ ] Donuts there has to
be a happy middle a happy medium there
doesn't have to be but I think there
should be anyways he just tells me I
know I'm sorry and doesn't make any
efforts out dis cupcake eatin jackass
I know I'm sorry you lazy [ __ ] I don't
want to come across as a shallow or a
[ __ ] you're not but how else should I
get him to get his ass on the elliptical
I generally want him to be healthier and
happier with the way he looks I would
love to hear any advice you and the
lovely Nia have thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself just tell him he looks like a
giant powdered donut with [ __ ] orange
filling coming out the top you know
honey just how unfuckable are you trying
to become I don't I don't know how to do
it I just like that he's saying it to a
guy so I feel like you you don't have to
really worry about his feelings that
much I just sit down and say I just you
know I'm worried about you and you just
keep saying I know I'm sorry and you're
not doing anything about it and it's not
acceptable to me and it should be
acceptable to you all right you're in
the prime of your life you should look
like it I guess you know the doctor Phil
Whaley be like why are you eating so
much what is it that you feel that
you're you're getting out of eating them
cupcakes what is it that you're not
dealing with
I don't know I it's not fair I would
just say listen back in January we mean
it made a pact to both lose weight I did
and you didn't I brought it up to you
and all you say is I know I'm sorry so
what the [ __ ] all right just say that in
a nice way it's not fair to you
you walking around looking like a happy
sash and then you got the Maisie day
pasty float jumping on top you're like a
[ __ ] bean bags full of talcum powder I
mean that's just not fair to you it's
not fair to you you tell him I'm not
looking for rock-hard ABS but I mean
Jesus Christ you [ __ ] got a couple of
mozzarella balls hanging off your
[ __ ] hips it's not sexy then he's all
sweaty it's like yeah it's yeah maybe
give a bad nickname I don't listen to me
I'm a mum mean I mean I got an icon that
guys I got a good hop I get me all right
boyfriend's weight from elite okay the
last one UFO conspiracy and Bob Lazar
Lazar I don't know hey there old Billy
barbershop quartet not sure if you heard
there's about this one yet but I know
you're into conspiracy theory see gotta
listen to Rogen's podcast with Bob Lazar
it's [ __ ] crazy he's been telling
this story since the 1980s so if he's
bullshitting him us or whatever I
commend him for keeping it going for 30
years but even Rogen believes him for
the most part do you don't know his
story he's basically a physicist who has
a degrees from Caltech and MIT and first
started his career at the Los Alamos
National Laboratory
he made the local newspaper after
putting a jet engine in the back of his
Honda which then got the attention of
the government of government officials
at s4 which from my understanding is a
lab at area 51 see that people yep you
put yourself out there you get a job
he eventually gets employed there and on
his first day he's briefed on all this
alien technology and his task to the
propulsion team working on power source
that operates the UFOs wait there's a
UFO there and he all of a sudden he's
working from day [ __ ] one hey welcome
to area 51
they didn't men in black them with that
little [ __ ] thing there anyway this
is where it gets crazy
alright so now I'm watching this Joe the
Joe Rogan episode here you make sure I
got this down here where is it where is
it hang on hang on hang on hang on
content it is episode one three one five
one three one five alright he eventually
gets employed there Baba this is where
it gets crazy now Bob claims that the
u.s. government has nine UFOs in their
possession and they're all powered by
this anti-gravity device that is
essentially a reaction list power source
ie zero exhaust Bob
Bob's purpose there was to figure out
how that power source worked Jesus which
would involve taking it apart oh my god
how scary would that be but one of the
craziest things he mentions is that one
of these aircraft were found on an
archaeological archaeology gene Hall dig
which is wild to think about how long
it's been here for yeah I don't think
that's that wild I always had a theory
that water was the nuclear waste from
the last people that [ __ ] up this
planet and everything you're seeing is
mutant [ __ ] [ __ ] and just because we
crawled out of it we vibe with it so we
think it's beautiful you know and in the
future you'll have like plastic [ __ ]
beings made out of water bottles of some
[ __ ] I don't know he only worked there
for about six months and then blew the
whistle in 89 he's a [ __ ] rat keep
your mouth shut
but since then he's been telling the
same story and this the details never
waver you know something I used to think
that people should rat out
before [ __ ] like this but you know
something watching the behavior of
people online
they shouldn't be privy to this
information they can't even handle the
Hillary Clinton loosens and [ __ ]
Donald Trump you know the other [ __ ]
can't handle [ __ ] Obama winning a
couple election I don't it's fine I know
you can tell him about [ __ ] UFOs why
can't I have that anti-gravity machine
in my [ __ ] trailer he had his birth
certificate in school records scrubbed
his house and business constantly get
raided by the FBI and other government
agencies and is discredited all the time
why don't they just try to kill my just
kill him they just do that but as time
goes on more things slowly come out to
validate the story like for example the
people at Los Alamos National Lab
claimed he never worked there but
there's an employee logbook from the 80s
with his name in it shown in the
documentary all right well there's also
a documentary that claims you know
Kourtney killed Kurt so I don't know
also he talks about how it s for they
had this biometric device that measured
the length of your finger bones because
they're they're unique to every
individual well why would they do that a
fingerprints are [ __ ] unique to every
individual why do you got to take it to
that level people said that science
fiction well maybe you could fake
fingerprints because they're external
people said that science fiction that's
not that science fiction's those don't
exist but recently pictures of this
device were released see below another
one is the existence of element 115
which is allegedly the power source of
the antigravity devices is of a few
years ago we can man make this element
in particle accelerators but it is very
unstable and decays within seconds in
the new next Netflix documentary Bob
says that he took a piece of element 1 1
5 from s4 and hit it and says that's why
his house / business keep getting rated
well why don't they just arrest you and
grab all your [ __ ]
anyways I thought this was extremely
interesting I linked the Joe Rogan
episode here for you and for a
documentary just search Bob Lazar on
Netflix personally I thought the Joe
Rogan podcast was much better than the
documentary but it's worth checking out
hope to catch in Jersey soon cheers
alright I'll watch it I want you to roll
him think I'm not gonna watch the
Netflix
I can't where I'm at I can't figure out
how to [ __ ] get on it anyways alright
well that's the podcast everybody did I
bring up everything I had to please once
again remember please watch the Ian
Edwards stand-up special July 12th on
Comedy Central all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on ya on Thursday